I am Iron Man cut for today's toys some
batteries just don't last long enough
but Duracell ultra power lasts up to 15
hours longer Iron Man
locked and loaded so you can supercharge
your Marvel Avengers toys Tirra sell
ultra power last longer up to 15 hours
longer there was an idea to bring
together a group of remarkable people to
help save the universe from paying too
much on their car in stores there's tape
in the break room what are you doing um
nothing Marvel Studios Avengers infinity
war in theaters April 2017 now where
were we a powerful threat calls for a
greater response
when there is a battle bring strength
[Music]
when there's a problem
seek answers
[Music]
when there's doubt
give hope
not tomorrow
not in a few years
[Music]
but right now join Marvel Studios
adventures infinity war and American
Airlines in this fight today
donate $25 or more you'll receive 10
American Airlines advantage miles for
every dollar you give visit stand up to
cancer org slash American Airlines to
learn more together we can save lives
reddit run from it
the end is near we're gonna need some
help
how you been buck not bad for the end of
the world
Jared don't fight for one
we fight for all of them
Avengers infinity war when you said we
were going to open what conduct to the
rest of the world this is not what I
imagined or give you imagine the
Olympics maybe even a Starbucks
everywhere April 27th
[Music]
you
you